all right i did it folks it is done what
a weird flex
yeah i got my platt in that game that
people wanted to love and the internet's
generally talked [ __ ] about because of
the bugs but hey got my plot love me
weird but i feel like there's a lot to
talk about in terms of my experience
playing cyberpunk 2077 but i played it
on a ps5 which i heard
is a lot less buggy than ps4 but the ps5
version is not that ps5
upgrade that we were promised is still
the ps4 version being played on a ps5
and there are still bugs so i'll talk
about some of them absolutely i will get
there there's
nothing i can really add to it there are
some hilarious videos
online just showing bugs hey you know
you might as well have fun with it
however there's enjoyment in this game
dare i say there's
greatness in this game it has nothing to
do with the corporation
that basically shot it in the kneecaps
to make their quota for the holiday
season no no but the devs they worked at
it there's love in this game
so let's talk about it
[Music]
cyberpunk 2077 fight the man
so cyberpunk 2077 is that 60 dollar
beta test that we all bought it's
basically thank
gta it's grand theft auto in a cyberpunk
world that's really all you need to know
there's a chip in your head that's
killing you and also keanu reeves
well not keanu reeves the characters
played by keanu reeves the consciousness
of johnny silverhand is also
in your head so he just comes to talk
some [ __ ] every once in a while you know
like joker
and arkham knight same thing so yeah you
have your main story and your side
quests and your side missions and you're
going around this cyberpunk world
it really shows how monumental blade
runner was because you see this you're
like this is blade runner really the
vibe i got with this it's
blade runner meets strange days meets
gta that's what i got to say about this
world this world's very
captivating it's very intoxicating it's
very immersive it was anything but
boring to me and that's where you see
the clear line between this
game that was still buggy upon release
and the game that the developers wanted
to make obviously they weren't the ones
to make this call because there's love
in this game
nailed it also a very mature game like
some of the
some of the scenes where you get down
even one of the story based scenes with
johnny silverhand one of the flashback
scenes you're like this is wow they're
just showing it all remember when the
hot coffee mod was like
the most controversial thing in games
it's nothing now that is
nothing when hooking up with a sex
worker on the corner the one that i
found love the disgusted look like just
the one i mean there's another one a
dude
but not my thing but whether it be that
or the general ambience like you're
going down
the seedy realm of the city
and it's just like you hear sex ambience
everywhere or a commercial comes on tv
when you're in the elevator it's just
like
it adds to this the vibe of the world
and the vibe of the world is an
interesting one it's not just because
it's
sex that adds to it but there's
something about the
grit in this game i just dug it i'm
telling a couple of my friends i would
love for this game to come out on vr
because if there is a vr world i could
go into like ready player one style and
just kind of
lose myself in it it would be the world
of cyberpunk 2077 i just like it also i
like the mission rollout
a lot to do a lot of side missions it
can get overwhelming in a game like this
but the game
keeps it in the guard rails and keeps it
in the pocket you'll get a call from the
police dispatchers like all right any
mercs who want to do this job
it's there and it's a job that you've
stumbled across so you're already there
when you get the call
to this job that you might want to go to
it's not like you'll get a call it's
like hey
across the city there's another job
you're like dude i'm already here
now i gotta go there no the jobs roll
out as you stumble across them and you
come across them it just kind of
keeps it feeling less overwhelming not
saying this is the first game to do that
but i'm just
glad that that's the system this game
did it was a variety of gameplay in the
game like this same with my mass effect
build for cyberpunk
i went with pistol sniper rifles and
hacking because just
generally you know there's going to be
things you want to hack into it'll
probably get you more money early on
it's just there's usually perks to go
along with that so that's what i did but
if you want to go in as a brawler you
can if you want to go in it's just guns
blazing you can there
builds you can have to do all that the
hacking mechanic was actually
really cool at first i was like i don't
understand this
but you know experience sticking with it
otherwise known as a youtube video
explaining it point is it's a really fun
complex mini game you run into
quite often in this game you get really
good at mapping out
all the numbers you're gonna push before
you even start plus you get your skill
and that skill tree up you get more
perks to the point where you get some
money
nerf everybody buff your quick hacks and
you just destroy lives i
did find that quick hacks a smart sniper
rifle
and a good strong pistol is really all i
needed that was my build from the
beginning of the game to the end of the
game i just
i never felt like i had to branch
outside of that except getting that one
trophy where you have to do superhero
landing on two people at the same time
which sucked would land on people and it
wouldn't hurt them or kill them
and it was stupid and that's like if i'm
going to jump to the bugs for a second
and address that that's the problem with
having a buggy game upon launch because
it creates this
antitrust throughout the entire game
between the player and the game like if
this game wasn't buggy and my superhero
landing wasn't working i'd be like all
right i'm obviously doing something
wrong i need to get to a higher place
though
i didn't record it when i did it i
jumped from like five
stories it just wasn't working but
because the game's all buggy i'm like
clearly it's the game's fault
it's just a bug and then like the next
day it was like oh no you got that
trophy yesterday i was like
when did that pop all right well okay
i guess i have it now but yeah i found
relying on quick hacks smart sniper
rifle and a good powerful pistol when
you run out of sniper rifle ammo
that's the great bill that was a great
build for me because i never found a
sniper rifle with a silencer on it
however i did have
quick hacks in which you could fry
someone's brain from like 50 yards away
and that was
fine that's probably the best sniper
rifle you can get in the game
is actually a quick hack and you just
melt their brains just
dead you build that up the refresh on
it's pretty generous you just start
melting brains from a distance and no
one really kills you the boxing mechanic
you know when you're
hand-to-hand fighting just nobodies it's
actually pretty gratifying to arc up and
just slug them and
the bases here oh yeah you're down
forever but there's this whole boxing
thing where you have to
face off against a few boxers they're
boxing matches but the boxing mechanic
is really
not well polished to the point where
it's getting so intense you're pushing
it in which means you're ducking and now
you're moving all slow then you get
slugged a couple times since the match
is over because i was kind of a glass
cannon you know it's like yeah i can
hack your brain i can shoot you from a
distance but please don't
shoot me or punch me i can't take that
many hits so i was pretty glad when the
game did
glitch when i'm taking on you know the
boss of the boxers and he just kind of
clipped into the ropes and he was just
stuck there and i was like okay well
all right not all bugs are bad i will
say there's the illusion
of variety in this game also in the
beginning you choose your backstory
where you come from i chose nomad
because you know
youtuber you know fight the man you
don't want to be tied down by companies
nah
free living free life nomad says the guy
working on youtube owned by google
which is clearly not the wild west it
once was which gives you
different dialogue options when you're
talking to people but really it's
all paths lead to the same thing kind of
like when you build up your
strengths you can rip doors open that
you otherwise couldn't or if you have
your intelligence your technology tree
you can hack doors and open them but
generally i found that there was just
another way into that room it just
wasn't
that door so i was like okay well you're
not getting some super secret stuff
i never got some game breaking gear
because of it even if it was an
exclusive door that you can only
open if you had that tear up there's
never that sarin moment you know there's
never that sarin moment
from mass effect where it's like i can
avoid this fight and just convince him
to
end it if i have my dialogue up like
there's no moment like that
in this game so building up these tiers
was never as important as the game made
it seem
the important thing is to level up one
skill to level 20. if you're looking for
a trophy that's where your trophy is for
me it was quick hacks if you're a trophy
hound it's more important than whatever
you're gonna find behind a locked door
also
crafting crafting in this game
is the worst again there's no trophy for
crafting so
at first i was breaking down gear like
yeah gear for crafting
and granted i got a couple of really
great guns
my pistol was a beast and my smart
sniper rifle
was a force to be reckoned with i was
guaranteed to get a head shot and that
head shot was going to hit for some
nasty damage i tell you this because
money
is important in this game if you want
your trophy because you have to buy all
of the cars in the game that gets
expensive there are no trophies for
crafting
plus crafting if you run out of
components you have to make more
components and this game has no good
grace to have you go okay i want 50 of
these components bump it up to 50 and go
craft done nope it's one by one
one two three
for as long as you need to to get like
one
pistol i was there for 15 solid minutes
which doesn't sound bad but it's bad
when you're like
press the button press the button
put and hold the button you gotta press
and hold it
it's tedious the crafting's [ __ ] of all
the patches
i'll take all the all the bugs that
break immersion
if they just fix the crafting that's the
thing i also do wish
there were more romance options in a
game like this like did the normandy i
was making my rounds in the normandy man
mass effect here i was like okay flirt
flirt flirt flirt yep i was that captain
i was captain james t kirk i didn't care
in cyberpunk
2077 you have one romance option i mean
you have two
if you want to hook up with the dude but
again not not my thing
so okay that's my one options pan am
that's her that's
not that i'm complaining she's pretty
cool until she gets kind of dramatic
like she was awesome and then
she was like fine whatever she would
just drama out and i was like
i like a game like this to give more
personality types more options
my favorite was judy a first of all like
hey judy what's up and i was like
oh she is not interested in dudes there
is no shot there
damn but i will say the friendship you
form with judy is actually pretty
awesome and i
liked the friendship that's another
thing this game has connections and
friendships
you form with people and those
connections and friendships are actually
they feel solid i liked him not the
least of which was
johnny silverhand played by keanu reeves
keon is amazing in this game
he's keanu reeves but he's keanu reeves
the self-destructive
rock star um imaginary friend who's not
imaginary it's actually his
consciousness i mean if i had to pick a
jiminy cricket
to be on my shoulder talking to me the
entire time i would probably be him i
just thought he was great i thought he
was amazing
and most importantly he's entertaining
and another thing i thought was lame
before we get into some of the bugs
was uh the xp and items and everything
you earn in the last mission
it doesn't carry over because of course
it's like oh hey you beat the game but
you know there's more to do so go out
there and you're like all right sweet
but everything you picked up everything
you earned everything you did from the
last mission doesn't carry over which
sucks because there was a lot of great
gear dropping i was like
i'm gonna sell all this stuff oh i'm
gonna get those cars and
none of it carries over it's like it
doesn't matter so don't even waste your
time picking anything up i thought that
was lame
i feel like that's just an easy patch
fix that they could do among the
many pages they're probably going to do
with this game so the game generally is
what you think it is
it's a fun immersive interesting dirty
seedy
cyberpunk world in which i've never felt
so much like a blade runner in my entire
life a lot of missions
side missions the core missions the core
story is not that long
so it's the side missions that really
fill it up and the side missions are a
lot of fun
i didn't think the game was too hard to
be honest with you in terms of
difficulty i usually play games actually
not usually
i always start a game out on normal
because normal i feel like is
where the developers were like this is
the optimum intended way to play the
game and if you want to
bump it one way or the other you totally
can and even then
it just wasn't that hard i had enough
healing i had enough quick hacks
it just people weren't going to live
through me in a world where i can
capture gameplay footage here is
official gameplay footage of me going
through the
final level of this game unstoppable
so if you're a first person shooter gta
veteran you might want to bump up the
difficulty a bit but you can do that mid
game i believe so
try it out and when you feel like god
just go ahead and bump the difficulty up
okay so the bugs the box are completely
and totally in this game
again i played it on ps5 was the ps4
version
on ps5 which i heard is less buggy than
the ps4 version
but the bugs are still there i didn't
run into anything game breaking it was
just
these little obnoxious bugs that just
hurt the immersion and that's annoying
absolutely i mean we all like immersion
especially
in an immersive world a world that's
supposed to be immersive there's nothing
worse you see some [ __ ] guy like just
doing this [ __ ]
what are you doing one time i got to the
next phase of a mission just
never triggered i was just sitting
around like an [ __ ] like what to do i
had to restart the mission then the game
crashed so i ended up having to do this
sequence three times but hey
nothing that my invisible gun can't
handle another one that cracked me up
i don't have footage for all of these
but i just i remember them these cops
are in a fire fight and i'm like oh here
i am
done i swoop in there and just take out
all the baddies and the cops like oh
on behalf of the force thank you very
much and the dude takes a step
he's like freeze i [ __ ] like
what happened
he starts just shooting me i was like
well well
you get a memory wipe i mean cyberpunk
it could happen and again maybe i did
something wrong maybe i
shot a cop in that in that crossfire
i don't know but i'm never gonna humor
that because the game's buggy so again
that disconnect that anti-trust between
the player and the game the game's just
buggy as [ __ ] the cops shot me after he
thanked me
dick it's kind of like and i noticed
this earlier on when i played the game
that at a point it stopped doing this
i don't know if i just got better at it
or if a patch that they did
just made this go away but when enemies
would see me it was like metal gear
solid one
where they'd see you like ah and then
everyone knew that this person saw you
and then later on as i kept playing
i had time to neutralize that person
before he got the word out and it was
like okay they don't know i'm here yet i
guess i'm asking your question more than
giving an answer i just found it
funny that i'm like so metal gear solid
2 advanced that we're talking a game
from 2002.
did it better than cyberpunk that's
weird
well you can say like oh wait no they
have cybertech so
they're linked mentally and everyone
knows if one person
but that's me making a stretch to
justify what's possibly a bug that may
or may not be a bug in the game and
that's really what the bugs are i didn't
even get pissed
when a car flies through the air
like it's the statue of liberty's head
from cloverfield or something that
happened a couple times just driving all
sudden you
see cars and in the background just blow
up everywhere it's just flying cars it's
raining cars you're like
why though or pan am sounds like she's
talking through a walkie-talkie when
she's two feet from me
the feeling of realizing that means
nothing if you're alone my
favorite was when i died on this roof
this roof had these mines on it and i
just got blown up
but there's an autosave there so my auto
save load was just a perpetual loop of
death
save often my friends because all of
this pales in comparison
to the reality that when you're playing
this game for any extended period of
time
you can count on you're going and then
the game stops
and then you just get that sinking new
feeling cuz
crash i reported it every time you
realize how many reports they're getting
from me alone it's crazy i can only
imagine how many people have reported
crashes in this game but yeah that was
really the most obnoxious one because
not everything you do
auto saves every mission well but these
little straggler things were like oh
there's a little straggler mission i'll
take care of that it doesn't necessarily
auto save
and so you're going and then freeze and
maybe you leveled up maybe you optimized
your gear maybe you're at
a little station you sold your gear
broke down gear or crafted something and
well that's gone now you have to do it
all over again so i found myself just
saving a lot
i saw this one youtube video where
someone's comparing cyberpunk to grand
theft auto 5 and how grand theft auto 5
does things better than cyberpunk like
if you aim a gun at someone in a car
cyberpunk they're all like please don't
i'm asking nicely gta 5 they're like
i wanna live just back the car up jump
out run off but in this video
dude shooting in the water in cyberpunk
is like there's no bullet splashes in
cyberpunk i'm like i'll do you one
better they're no body splashes either
which isn't a bug that's just crappy
programming just like
people not fleeing for their lives in
their cars when you aim a gun at them
that's just crappy ai but it's crappy
programming that under normal
circumstances under a normal release
schedule had it not been rushed would
have been ironed out before release but
that's that's what the bugs are
for me in this game anyway but it's just
a series of little bugs that
broke immersion throughout the game you
can feel where it's
clunky here clunky there it's just it's
a complete-ish game it's just
not polished that that fine-tuning
that's the difference between a beta
and the final release but in that that's
why i'm not even pissed at the
developers i'm sure the developers are
as
pissed as the rest of us because in this
game you can feel
the love of this world you can feel the
fact that they worked on this game for
years and the developers knew that which
we all now know
which is this game should have been
delayed for another year but the devs
work for the company who answered to the
investors and everyone above the
developers wanted to make their fiscal
year
they wanted to make their holiday quota
which is why i'm looking forward to the
patch
i hope it gets patched i it will
eventually
get patched to be a complete and
wonderful game a game which
people can then dive into and have that
experience of cyberpunk that was
intended from the beginning
bummer is this game broke sales records
so for a lot of people
it's going to be the second impression
there's no second first
impression but i thought the world was
interesting it was gritty it was dirty
it was very blade runner blade runner
meets
strange days like i said there's
actually one segment in here it's blade
runner
meets strange days meets eight
millimeter it was dirty it was hard it
was gritty and i enjoyed being on this
investigative
path to get to the end to take down some
scumbags it has a good philosophy again
the philosophy is not
new but it's interesting to see the line
between what is consciousness what is
not
what are we at what point do you lose
yourself if we are if our soul
is the aggregate of our memories how
much can you [ __ ] with that
until you're not you anymore this world
really grabbed me i'd dream about it i'd
wake up in the morning and be excited to
revisit it
[Music]
don't worry she'll be fine but in order
to really experience all that you have
to do something you shouldn't have to do
which is look past the wall of bugs but
if you can't look
past it i totally get it this means
you're human
you shouldn't have to look past it but
that is to say when they finally do
patch this game to be the game it was
supposed to be upon release
i say give it a shot because i think you
might really dig it that's the new
rating i'm going with
definitely get this absolutely when it's
all patched up
be honest with me now and tell the truth
this reminded you of death stranding
don't lie
all right so cyberpunk 2077 have you
played it does the bugs irritate you
can you just look past them are you
waiting until the bugs are gone to play
it what's your stance what do you think
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more
click right here to see more
you